so look I'm not a big fan of emotional
baggage and here's what I mean by a lot
of times people have a certain conflict
with their parents but they're afraid to
bring it up and for the rest of their
lives they have something in their mind
here that they're hanging on to could be
it's like a hundred pounds you're
carrying your entire life just because
you're afraid of having some serious
conversations with your parents I've had
so many of them with my parents today I
want to share with you a few
conversations you need to have with your
parents look one of the first
conversations gotta have with your
parents is for them not to impose their
fears on you and I'm explained to what I
mean by not imposing their fears on you
this happens so often it's a they're not
doing it intentionally they're not
trying to hurt you
there is no negative intentions it's
just they failed they have pants that
they want to pass it on to you in a way
of thinking that to protect and you let
me give you an idea what happened the
other day the other day someone text me
I have a text that you can text me now
this is what the number is gonna be
somewhere around here
this kid text me says I'm sitting with
my grandpa we're watching one of your
videos and while I'm showing him this
video about being an entrepreneur my
grandfather says be careful starting a
business or being inspired that these
things are possible because when you do
fail it's very painful when you do fail
right and he's saying this is what
should I say to my grandfather what
would you tell him I said have your
grandfather read this I said I hope your
grandpa is not imposing his fears and
failures on his grandson because if he
does his grandson will also have the
same fears and failures that he had he
responds back to me says that was a deep
message I showed it to my grandpa he had
nothing to say why you know why because
that's exactly where the grandpa went oh
he thought about is oh my gosh all I
just did with this 22-year old soul who
has the ability to go out and build
something significant I just shared my
feel fears insecurities and failures
with him what if he believes it then
he's just gonna go be average and
ordinary so it's very important for you
to sit there and say look mom looked at
I just want to tell you I love you you
have no idea how much I love you you've
done this for me you've done that form
you've done this for me but I got to
tell you sometimes I feel like you're
passing your fears and failures on me
and I don't
to be that person I understand didn't
work out for you would Bob you
understand didn't work out for you with
your uncle or your brother but I want to
go out and build a business and I need
you to support me or don't say anything
negative to me about my business I need
you to leave me alone there
can you please support me there and I
see what they're gonna do with it and
what kind of a Cobra maybe a little bit
of friction but I guarantee even after
friction a dealer later two days later
today that's it it later they're gonna
say you know what I'm proud of my son
that he can have these kinds of tough
conversations son will support you
that's the first conversation I have
with them the next thing you gotta talk
to your parents about is certain things
that they said while you were growing up
that's stuck with you that you believe
it that may not be the truth it's your
parents truth that's been passed down to
you but it's created some kind of a
limiting belief in you that's got to be
addressed let me talk about what I'm
saying in this part you I grew up and my
mother we had a relative she would
always say things about this relative he
was the wealthiest person in our
relative we say oh my gosh bad person
all he cares about is money greedy all
this other stuff every time I would see
this man as a kid I'll kind of look at
him like this just kind of like you know
what a greedy man you are and I can't
believe he said because I'm loyal to who
my mom I'm loyal to my mom that's my mom
why wouldn't I be loyal to my mom
fast forward years later I'm 1314 years
old we're in the u.s. okay
so I go to this guy's house once a year
my dad would take me 7200 square foot
house next door neighbor to Snoop Dogg
in Upland San Antonio if you know the
area anyways California and he had a
tennis court basketball court swimming
pool garden fruits pool table office
pictures with Al Gore presidents one
picture of his entire family would white
in a morning when they would have
breakfast the 2030 people would come
together cuz they all lived together
they would have breakfast I would see
how this kids always wanted to be around
him look wait a minute if this guy's so
bad who knows more bad things about him
than his own kids
why do his kids want to be around him I
don't care if other people don't want to
be around me if my kids who know me the
best want to be around me I'm a winner
am I not fast for what I'm 33 years old
okay my mom and I have a sit down in her
kitchen and I said well can I ask you a
question said yes why don't you not like
this person you realize you made me not
like rich people because of what stuff
you said about it why do
see the stuff you said about him and my
mother have so much respect for us she
said you know what Pat at that time I
didn't like the fact that when he became
rich he couldn't spend time with us
anymore and we wouldn't see him as much
as we used to anymore I didn't like that
to me it felt like he was being snobby
because he made a lot of money I said
well mom when this guy starts building a
business and an empire it's kind of
tough to go and try to spend time and
accommodate time with everybody you just
don't have that kind of time I relate
because I'm your son now and I've
experienced that she says no I get it
now but that's what it was at that time
I said oh my gosh for 33 years I believe
this for 33 years I believe this 50
pounds off my back that was just some
fear that was passed down to me some of
the things out you may have heard from
your parents may be different than what
I said but you've got to go ask them
because if you don't their truth will be
your truth even though it's not the
truth so look this next one is in every
relationship you need to be kind of
doing this even with your boyfriend
husband you know wife girlfriend sitting
there with your mom and dad and saying
this is what I need from you very simple
what is it you need for me whatever it
is you do
I remember one time I pull my dadís I
said dad I need you to start telling me
you love me it was 21 years old I got
out of the army I've never heard my dad
say I love you and he says you want me
to tell you I love you I said I want you
to tell me you love me say you love me I
want to hear it he says you are becoming
American I tell you what is this I love
you you know I love you I don't need to
tell you I love you I say you need to
tell me you love me he says I don't tell
you I love you already know I love you
he gets upset he walks off I said what's
the matter with this guy so I leave I go
to work the next day Bally Total Fitness
I get a call Pat your father's calling
you on line one
my dad's calling me he never calls me at
work because he thinks it's
disrespectful he would never do smite
that is he thinks when people's family
called them at work they're insulting
the business that's my bad so I pick up
I said dad what's up
he says aha how's work work is good dad
ok ok good ok I said dad you ok yes ok
ok ok I love you click it's the matter
with this guy the phone then I get
another call Patrick your sister online
so I'm like why is my sister calling my
office my dad Jim run it she
cause me lying too so I pick up the call
my sister calls in right so I pick up
the comment I pull out what's up she
says did you speak to dad today I said
yeah why is he okay I said you know what
why sis just called me he said I love
you and he hung up but he really says
yeah I said he's okay last night I had a
conversation with him I said you got to
start telling your kids you love him and
she's like oh I thought he was having
heart issues he's totally fine I went
home and by the way from that day till
today my dad says I love you more than
we say it to him now because he loves
saying I love you to me to my wife to
his daughter to his you know grandson
granddaughter to everybody he's all
about love now but we had to have that
conversation so rather than being upset
with your parents cuz they don't say it
have the conversation with them the next
one is if you have kids this is not to
everybody that doesn't have kids but you
can think about this one day when it
happens how you plan on raising your
kids and what does this mean some of the
things your parents did maybe you don't
like you know some of the things your
parents didn't do maybe you wanted to
and they may not want to do it's just a
conversation trap to say look you know
you could be disciplined your kids in a
certain way and your mom or your father
undermines you in front of them wait a
minute what just happened right here can
I have a conversation with you guys this
is how I'm planning on raising my kids I
understand they're your grandkids I love
it but this is how I'm raising my kids
and these are things that are very
important to me there could be very
simple things the fact that you don't
want the kids to watch TV freely all day
long you just hand them the remote your
parents may think that's okay you have
to tell them that's not okay my kids
maybe the fact that you want your kids
to read but you didn't grow blue reading
maybe you want your kids to play outside
but you're gonna play outside maybe you
want your kids to be inside well you
grew up on the answer it doesn't matter
whatever it is that is important to you
this is not nitpicking stuff to me it's
not like 50 different things it's really
three different things I'm not bringing
up with a list of hey let me go through
a list of 55 different things that I
want to give you an a manual on how to
do this for my kids no but it is certain
conversations in this household
we're raising our family as Christians
we're not talking about God here and our
family we're gonna be doing this and our
family we believe in this these are the
things that I want to raise my kids with
I think a lot of times when you have
that conversation it's a little bit
uncomfortable at first for them because
I like who are you
me how to do this because I'm your I'm
your parent you know I had you you tell
me how to talk to your grandkids are you
out of your mind but you need to have
the conversation because they're not
gonna spend as much time around your
kids as you're gonna spend around your
kids and one day the responsibilities
are your kids turn out is now gonna be
the grandparents it's gonna be the
parents you need to kind of control the
point of contact now it's a different
story if you're living in a cultural
family with grandparents are there and
they're spending more time with your
kids than you are they have the
authority to say some of this stuff
because they're running more than you
but for the most part you need to have a
conversation with them and tell them how
you plan on raising your kids this next
one's a tough one for a lot of people
because they're uncomfortable talking
about their parents finances with them
it's like you know I've been in the
financial industry for now nearly 20
years as an advisor Morgan Stanley and
now ourselves and you would go sit down
with people and said tell me about your
parents you know what kind of financial
situation are there or they relying on
you I don't know are your parents on
track to be to retire I don't know I
can't tell you how many people who tell
me I don't know I said how do you not
know we can't have that conversation
we've never had that conversation why
have you not had that conversation have
you spoken about long-term care where do
they want to live do they want to be
taking care of do they want to stay at
and all folks some didn't want to stay
home you know what about final expenses
they don't want the kids to have a you
know falling-out between the kids
because a lot of times parents want the
kids to stay together when they die
right but a lot of times because parents
don't prepare to have these tougher
conversations when a parent dies and
there's some kind of a will the money is
being fought within siblings and then
all of a sudden there's a falling-out
among siblings because the parents
didn't have their finances in order so
in reality it was a parent's fault on
the way they handle their finances so if
you don't have these conversations one
day could lead to a falling-out between
the family members and I promise you
your parents don't want that so you need
to sit down and have the conversation
with them about money and finances where
they're currently at and what direction
they need and will kind of help they're
gonna need a long term look this next
conversation sometimes uncomfortable on
yourself as well as your parents because
you know like when you talk about health
with your parents and it comes down to
possibly talking about length of living
and heart and all this stuff parents
don't want their kids to talk to them
about dying you know like you're talking
to me as if you want me to die because
it's sensitive like it it can come
across
that way sometimes and for the right
reasons because as you get older too one
fear that's on your mind all the time is
dying it's no longer the fear of being
accepted or friends or being cool or
finding a girl or finding you know kids
it's am I gonna live long am I gonna die
what's gonna happen to me and so when it
comes down to health it's encouraging
physicals dad when's the last time you
got your heart checked out who's your
doctor relationship with the doctor
depending on the age your father or your
mother is having something with them
that if something goes down they press a
button 9-1-1 gets called you know
everything with that is purely
preparation how are your teeth how's
your you know bones doing tell me how
you're doing with your hair for some
people hair gets thinner you need to
have those conversations what is it that
you want to be able to feel confident
about yourself but these are things
about help they need to have a
conversation with because myself my
dad's had 13 heart attacks okay he's got
three stents in his heart 50% of his
heart is a black one when I mean black
it means it's dead half his heart is
dead so we've had to have this
conversations a long time ago because he
was a smoker and he drank a lot when he
was younger so some of these things are
tough conversations to have but normally
when you're having more of a serious
conversations your energy and your
spirit needs to be a lower calmer they
can go here you need to stay here and
even if there's mutual siblings come
together and say mom we won't have a
conversation with your dad we won't have
a conversation with you we love you we
kind of want to know where you're on
health-wise we kind of think that this
smoking things got to be dropped because
it's really hurting you well you need to
have that conversation and even if they
go here you cannot go there because you
won't get any results you got to figure
out a way stay here even though you're
dying to go here try to control yourself
to stay here when having a tough
conversation with them this next one's a
little weird because as people get older
kids think parents no longer have dreams
right so my dad's seven years old what
kind of dreams is gonna have I'm like
that six years old what do you mean he
has dreams so for me I would ask my dad
I would say dad what are some your
dreams what are you talking about what
do you want to do what do mean what do I
want to do what do you want to do well
what are some things you want to do I
don't know what what do you want to do I
would mind going to Hawaii okay great
what do you want to do I wouldn't mind
going and white like one day I told my
dad said that you got to tell me what
you want to do dreams right because
these are things that
this family and parents too want to live
longer sometimes we forget to ask dreams
from people as they get older because
dreams is the only conversation we have
with kids and young adults but we don't
do it with somebody that's 60 70 80
years old says it dad I want you to
think about some of the things you want
to do what does he want to do my dad
call me out of the blue one day and he
says you know what I wanted Esther
what's that he said the US Open is this
week I want to go to us and you're
serious yeah you you wanna you wanna
which US Open golf or tennis tennis you
follow tennis I like tennis just when
you follow tennis how do you I've never
seen you hold the racket what n is
I like 10-yr you like tennis may dollars
in the finals you don't need now of
course I don't know you watched tennis I
love tennis so we're going back and
forth so Q so what do you want to do you
said you told me I want to go what do
you want I want okay let's go so what so
I booked the flight we went to New York
we got tickets Bill Gates was there all
these guys were there in the middle of
the match I have my dad say something on
snapchat US Open picks it up ESPN picks
it up within five hours it's got 600,000
views his friends are texting and saying
you're on snapchat he still doesn't know
what snapchat is it's being shown all
over the place he's having the time of
his life and to him that's like hey
that's great what are we doing next so
it's very very important for you to have
a sit-down with your parents and say mom
won't see me dreams what are some things
you want to do dad what are some of the
things you want to do you will be blown
away by their reaction and you're gonna
love having this conversation with them
so this next one is purely for you and
I'm explaining to what I mean by this is
purely for you it's asking them the
deeper history the family you know how
sometimes you know a little bit and I'm
not talking about just family tree like
homework you did back in high school or
junior high school or fourth grade fifth
grade I'm talking about for yourself
like you listen who was grandpa honestly
tell me about some crazy stuff about
grandpa who was grandma who was I'm more
like who were you more like what was
some of the things you guys faced what
was your mom and dad's relationship how
was your relationship with grandpa well
what is this whole thing about with the
Syrians who are we really how do you
view a serious how do you view Armenians
whatever you may be how do you view
people from Honduras how do you view
people from Puerto Rico how do we
Vietnamese folks or what do you think
about us what is the thing with what we
really stand for you're asking them
these questions who were you in high
school you're in
interviewing them you know I literally
have a two-hour interview with my dad
that I did three years ago it's never
been shared anywhere it's for me he says
why are you interviewing me I said what
do you mean why am i interviewing you
why are why is this guy I told you I
don't like this camera stuff put this
camera stuff away I said do you like
your grandkids of course I like my
grandkids what kind of a stupid question
is this I said let me tell you why I'm
doing this interview because one day
your grandkids would you like to have
video of your grandpa where you can sit
down and watch your grandpa talk one day
says of course I see your grandkids are
gonna be able to watch you speak in this
video because you're gonna give them
life advice uh-huh okay let's do the
camera bring the camera you know that we
had the conversation together but it's
it's to get the deeper history of family
because I can tell you there's one thing
that if you were sitting right here in
front of me within 5-10 minutes today I
had somebody who's a whistle blower sat
right in front me right here she was
sitting right in from me before we shot
this video and she's the whistleblower
from Cambridge analytical we're sitting
here talking and we're obviously talking
about what happened with the election
and Trump and brexit and all this a
Facebook and by the time I go into it
preach I said tell me about your parents
start talking about her parents sure a
grandpa my grandpa was a military
intelligence 27 years my mom was working
at Enron my that was a real estate
person my you know family's Jewish and
Poland and Russia and all this stuff
right am i he's telling us she's tell
all these stories do you know what
happened all of a sudden she starts
crying she gets emotional what a smile
on her face you know why because when
you go deeper in your family history
roots it's happy and emotional because
it's you it's a part of you it's a
beautiful thing and imagine you don't
have those conversations with them this
is why it's a good idea to set up a time
to go sit down with your parents and ask
them some questions about your family
history
I promise you you'll be blown away by it
this may not apply to a lot of you guys
because if your parents are together
then you don't need to have this
conversation but if your parents are
divorced this sensitive conversation
about getting remarried right now if
your parents don't have a problem
getting remarried and they've done it a
few times you don't need this video this
doesn't apply to you
but I'm talking about some of you guys
that have parents where they don't want
to get remarried gotta ask him why guy
I've asked this question both from my
mom and my dad because in the Middle
Eastern culture both my parents are very
proud and and their kids matter a lot to
them both of them like their kids mad a
lot to my mom and the kids matter a lot
for their kids my mother kids we matter
a lot to her and we matter a lot to my
dad and many times they don't do it
because they're afraid of losing your
relationship it's not an easy one let me
explain to you why because this is tough
to describe but you can take it any way
you want we as kids are greedy we want
all the attention okay and if somebody
from the outside comes in that is
possibly gonna take that attention away
from you and get mom's attention now
more than she gives to you or dad gets
attention from somebody else than you
you may think you're okay with it but
you may not be okay with it but if it
helps them have somebody to have a
conversation with long-term if it helps
them have somebody go to dinner with
somebody to go with movies with to have
fun with to have private time with and
it makes them a happier person you got
to be able to find a way to support it
but a lot of times they don't do it it's
because they're worried about how you
think about them and they're worried
about possibly losing your love and the
kid love is different than any other
companion you may have this may be
cultural again it may not matter to any
one of you that are watching this maybe
there's only like you know a few of you
that are watching and saying that that's
exactly to me and my parents maybe you
got to have a conversation with them and
let them free and set them free and tell
them say mom if you I think it's a good
idea for you to find somebody that I
think got you maybe 68 but you you're 68
you still got 20 30 more years to live
why not what's wrong with it
it's a it doesn't matter they're gonna
do it but they're gonna be free if you
have that conversation with them and
they're not gonna bring it up to you
it's a lot better if you bring it up to
them you know this last one is an
interesting one because just the other
day Emmitt Smith the running back his
son everybody was wondering what college
he's gonna go to now Emmitt Smith went
to Florida Gators right and it's this
interesting scene where his son
the father is hoping he goes to Florida
to keep it in the family but the son
says I'm taking my talents to Stanford
okay now the media is all watching what
the dad's reaction is gonna be me tell
what the dad says in front of media says
listen we I would like my son to be a
Florida Gator matter of fact he puts the
Hat on I am a gator but we've raised our
sons to make the right decisions for
themselves at the stage of their lives
they're at I support my son to want to
go to Stanford I'm aware does that I can
wear the hat this hat he doesn't have to
wear this hat you know his daddy went
here that doesn't mean that my son has
to go there if they were at the end of
the day my son has his own journey and
it is his journey not my journey and for
him to do the things that is best for
him is what we teach all of our children
to find what is best for you and go make
it happen for yourself what a moment why
is this such a special moment is because
that son was tough enough to make that
decision to go there it's a reflection
of the character the parents passed on
to their kids that respect goes to the
parents you're under someone that some
makes that kind of a decision a father
sitting right next to them I tip my hat
off to Emmitt Smith the father and a
mother write what they did you also need
to have a conversation with your parents
and tell them what your dreams are and
who you want to be
it may not be aligned with what they
want you to be I got three kids believe
me one day my kids they're gonna have
strong personalities because I'm their
father they're gonna sit me down and say
dad here's kind of what I want to do my
life you're an entrepreneur your
business all good I have no desire to
want to do that I want to go be a lawyer
I want to go make movies I want to go
tell stories I want to go do this and as
long as I've taught him the right way of
thinking and processing and they come to
me and tell me that and they're serious
about their decision I might say son
honey baby you got my support babies go
do what you want to do but if you don't
have that conversation with your parents
they're gonna be confused half the time
your parents don't believe your dreams
are that serious to you they don't
really bother him you may go tell your
parents about it and they may
blow you off that doesn't mean they
don't support you that means they just
don't believe you yet and it's on you to
convince them that you're fully support
about your dreams because a lot of times
kids want to go tell their parents one
day is this one day is that one day is
this one day is that one day is this of
course your parents are not gonna
believe you but if you go tell them
here's what I want to do and you deliver
on it you will gain the level of respect
from your parents that you never had
before so go have that conversation with
your parents about what your dreams are
as the longest you are crystal clear
about your dreams and you're willing to
put the work behind it to have your
dream become a reality you know it's
crazy actually want to hear about the
experience you have with sitting out
with your parents send me a tweet at
Patrick video send me a text at 3 103 4
0 1 1 3 2 I actually want to hear you
have these conversations with your
parents and how it goes because it's
gonna be you need a unique experience I
got another video I want you to watch it
has to do some what about this and this
is more about who to marry and how to
marry a lot of times people ask me
questions who do i marry how do I marry
so I finally made a video about it's
probably one of the most entertaining
videos I've done so if you haven't
watched it click over here who to marry
how to Marian if you haven't yet
subscribe to the channel click over here
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]